hey guys Ryan right here today I'm going
to be watching the official trailer for
Mission Impossible rogue nation I
thought I was watching the official one
the other day apparently I was just a
teaser trailer so I already did a whole
talk on it there's a failed livestream
event that I tried out didn't really
make a lot of people do too happy for
all you guys who hated on me for it it
was an experiment and if you want to
keep insulting me I [ __ ] all your
mother's just so you know but I am
really excited friend it's Murphy the
IMF is uniquely trained and highly
motivated specialists without equal
immune to any countermeasures but it is
an agency of chaos
the time has come to dissolve the IMF
and I want you to choose your next words
very carefully
[Music]
last I heard he was tracking the sink
[Music]
now when the CIA has never discovered
any Intel regarding the syndicate
deployed answer for the truth
we've definitely met before right
Thank You Easter where are you syndicate
is real
a rogue nation trained to do what we do
they're coming after us with everything
they've got
three percent mission impossible babes
our last mission smooth account of the
pike you want to bring down the
syndicate
it's impossible
[Music]
ah desperate times
does four measures
figures he passed on to us to be out now
oh hey boys look at us
tips
Oh
ah
why
[Music]
but they bought the red logo back of the
mission impossible or has it always been
red this whole time no it's always been
red I'm stupid I don't know why I said
that
I hope they used IMAX cameras again I'm
not sure if they did but I hope that
airplane scene is shot with IMAX cameras
because I remember watching that scene
in Dubai and ghost Protocol and IMAX
that was [ __ ] intense I can only
imagine how intense that would be on
IMAX I saw this in the teaser trailer
review this film is like combining
elements from all the mission
Impossibles actually you know I thought
it was mainly just taking from 3 & 4 but
now I'm looking at this whole trailer I
see that's barring from 1 & 2 as well
and as well as a Christopher McQuarrie
adding his own kind of suspenseful twist
to it it might not be the most personal
one like mission impossible 3 will
probably always have that one but this
looks like it still could be the darkest
one of them all I like how it's not
forgetting to lose its fun elements that
Ghost Protocol had it's honoring
everything we loved about Ghost Protocol
but it's bringing it back to more of
that like dark kind of thriller that the
first Mission Impossible was and that
part three is it's even got like some
familiarity with part two part two is my
least favorite especially the motorcycle
sequences like that just automatically
makes me remember part two I like this
new chick she's [ __ ] hot Wow holy
crap she's sexy very sexy she's becoming
a new Hollywood crush for me already
it's one thing I really respect about
this whole mission impossible franchise
is that they keep changing directors and
each film has its own type of vibe to it
I mean that's what always keeps it
interesting is that each movie has a
different Flair to way part two doesn't
feel like part 1 part 3 is a failure
part 2 part 4 does it feel like part 3
this one looks very different it looks
unique I'm really digging it I love
seeing Simon Pegg more in the field too
like that's gonna be a blast to watch
you know one point in shows he gets
captured [ __ ] mask is taken off and I
like how the trailer showing you know
the hole he gets captured scene and then
he breaks his way out those kinds of
scenes are always [ __ ] cool you always
know you got a good action hero when
he's captured but breaks out there and I
think Tom Cruise can do that in real
life he just has that smile that could
take a man
and a nice cook but if you want to hear
a little bit more insight into this
actually did a livestream where I had
you know fans asking questions about the
movie to hear more thoughts about it so
if you want to hear more insight to what
I think my theories and hypotheses go
check that video out anyway guys thanks
for telling me that was out if you're
new to the channel you can subscribe to
the real rejects and you can follow us
on Facebook Instagram and Twitter where
today I'm probably going to be tweeting
about how depressed I am now that I
finished Entourage this is why I don't
like getting too invested in shows
because when they end it makes me so
depressed Mac's hammer
hey Ryan give me a shout-out please by
the way if you don't I will hunt you
down and [ __ ] on your face next hammer I
might like you to do that if you want to
[ __ ] on my face you know
Veronica's never been willing to do it
but I be down everybody this is the face
of the man who will be [ __ ] on my
face he looks like Goku and Jung the
shout-out is a bad idea